hello this is Matthew from simply Lyon
and today we're going to dig through
what docker is and how you could be
using it within your own DevOps
environment so let's get started in this
presentation we're gonna go through a
number of key things we're going to
compare docker versus traditional
virtual machines and what are the
differences and why you'd want to choose
docker
over a virtual environment we'll go
through the advantages of working with
docker and the structure and how you
would build out a docker environment and
during that structure we'll dig through
the components and the advanced
components within docker at the end of
the presentation we'll go through some
basic commands and then show you how
those basic commands can be used in a
live demo so with all that said let's
get started so those first we'll compare
docker with a traditional virtual
machine so here we have the architecture
on the left and right of a traditional
virtual machine versus a darker
environment and there are some things
that you'll probably see immediately
that are big differences one is that the
virtual environment has hypervisor layer
whereas the document has a docket engine
layer and then in addition to that there
are additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a
doctrine environment and a virtual
machine environment so with a virtual
machine the actual memory usage is very
high whereas with darker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degra gating and
starts getting poorer whereas with
docker
the performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability and contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container
and have the guarantee that the solution
will work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
at the boot up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a doctor
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it both that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with docker
if you have nine gigs and six gigs
becomes free that free memory can then
be reallocated and reused across other
containers used within that docker
environment another challenge is running
multiple virtual machines in a single
environment that can lead to instability
and performance issues whereas docker is
designed to run multiple containers in
the same environment and actually gets
better the more containers you run in
that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that VM
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a VM it just takes a long time
you talk about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds it takes for a docker
environment to boot up so let's dig into
what doctor actually is and what allows
for these great performance improvements
over a traditional VM environment so
docker itself is an OS virtualized
software platform and it allows IT
organizations to really easily create
deploy and run applications as what are
called docker containers that if all the
dependencies
within that container very easily and
the container itself is really just a
very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can there be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our dev ops lifecycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're building the code and you're
actually testing the code having a
container running the solution at those
stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really you
can use docker in multiple stages within
your DevOps cycle but it becomes really
valuable in the deployment stage so
let's look at some of the key advances
that you have with daca some things that
we've already covered is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself is
highly portable and was designed for
that in mind the efficiencies that
you'll see will allow you to run
multiple docker containers in a single
environment as compared to more
traditional VM environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called gamal which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is a security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and I'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key terms for the agile
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how dr.
actually works within your environment
so docker works
there is a what's called a docket engine
the docket engine is really comprised of
two key elements so you have a server
and a client and the communication via
the tooth is via REST API the server as
you can imagine has the instructions
that are communicated out to the client
and instructs the client on what to do
the connection between the client and
the server the communication is via a
REST API on older systems you can take
advantage of the docker toolbox which
allows you to go ahead and control the
docket engine the doctor machine docker
compose and kitematic so let's now go
into what the actual root components
though of docker are so let's have a
look at those key components there are
four components that we going to go
through we have the docker client and
server we have docker images we have the
docker registry and the docker container
we go step through each of these one by
one
so let's look at the docker clients and
server first so the docker client and
server is a command line instructed
solution where you would use terminal on
your Mac or command line on your PC or
Linux system to be able to issue
commands from the docker daemon the
communication between the docker client
and the docker host and is via a REST
API so you can do similar communication
such as a docker pull command which
would send an instruction to the daemon
which would then form the interaction of
pulling in the correct components such
as an image or container a registry to
the docker client the daca daemon itself
is actually a service which actually
performs all sorts of operating and
performance services and as you'd
imagine the docker daemon is constantly
listening across the REST API to see if
it needs to perform any specific
requests if you want to trigger and
start the whole process you what you
want to do is use the command docker
within your docker daemon and that will
start all of your performances and then
you have a docker host which regi runs
the docker daemon and registry itself so
now let's look into the actual structure
of a docker image so a doctor image
itself is a template which contains
instruction
for the docket container and that
template is written with a language
called e Amal and Yael stands for yet
another markup language it's very easy
to learn the docker image itself is
built within that ya know file and then
hosted as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers when you start with your base
layer which will typically have your
base image in this instance it's your
base operating system such as a bun tune
and then you then have layer of
dependencies above that this would then
comprise the instructions in a read-only
file that would become your docker file
so as you go through and look at what
one of those instead some instructions
would look like so here we have four
layers of instructions we have a from
pull run and then command so what does
that actually look like in our layers so
to break this down the from creates a
layer which is based on Ubuntu and then
what we're doing is we're adding in
files from the docker repository onto
that base command of that base layer and
then what we want to be able to do is
then say okay what are the wrong
commands so we can see them build the
container within the environment and
then we want to be able to then have a
command line that actually executes
something within that container and in
this instance the command is to run
Python so one of things that we you will
see is that as we set up multiple
containers at each new container is a
new layer with new images within the
doctor environment each container is
completely separate from the other
containers within your doctor
environment so you're able to create
your own separate readwrite instructions
within each layer what's interesting is
that if you delete a layer then the
layer above it will also get deleted so
what happens when you pull in a layer
but something has changed in the record
image what's interesting then is that
the actual main image of itself cannot
be modified once you've copied the image
you can then modify it locally we can
never modify the actual base image
itself so here are some cool
for the components within a docket match
so the base layer are in read-only
format the layers can be combined in a
union file system to create a single
image the union file system saves memory
space by avoiding duplication of files
and this allows a file system to appear
as a writable but without modifying the
file which is known as a copy-on-write
the actual base layers themselves are
read-only so to be able to get around
this structure within a docker container
the doctor's environment itself uses
what's known as a copy-on-write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across the entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go into item
number 3 which is the docker registry so
the docker registry itself is the place
where you would host and distribute the
different types of images that you have
created or you want to be used with in
your environment the actual repository
itself is just a collection of docker
images and those docker images are built
on instructions that you would write
with yamo and are very easily stored and
shared and what you can actually do is
you can actually associate specific name
tags to the actual docket images
themselves so it's easy for people to be
able to find and share that image within
the doctor registry itself one of the
things you actually see as we go through
the demos you actually see us actually
using the the tag name and you'll see
how it is an alphanumeric identifying
how we actually use it to actually
creates the actual container itself one
of the things you can do to as start-off
how you would manage a registry is you
can actually use the publicly accessible
docker hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and
this may be for various reasons of how
you'd structure your environment the
actual commands you would use to
actually connect to the rest area both
push and pull push is to actually push a
new container environment you've created
from your local manager node to the
remote registry and a pool allows you to
pull up new clients that has been
created and is being shared
so again pool command and it pulls and
retrieves a docket image from the docker
registry and makes it very easy for
people to share different images
consistently across teams and a push
command allows you to take a new command
that you've created a new container that
you've created and push it to the
registry whether it's docker hub or
whether it's your own private registry
and allow it to be shared across your
teams some key did you know in docker
registry deleting a repository is not a
reversible action so we delete a
repository it's gone so that's going to
the final stage here which is the actual
docker container itself so the docker
container itself M is an executable
package of applications and it's
dependencies bundled together so gives
all the instructions that you would have
for the solution that you're looking to
run it's actually really lightweight and
again this is because of the redundancy
that's built in to how you structure the
container and the container itself is
then inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from group to
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host OS
securities or unique set ups as you
would have in a VM or a non
containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a doctor
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a VM you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each VM environment the challenge
you start running into though is that
you can't share that memory words with
docker you can easily share the memory
and for a single environment across
multiple containers the actual
tanner is built using docket images and
the command taichi run those images is a
run command I saw this got to go through
a basic structure of how you would run a
docket image so you go into terminal
window and you would write and docker
run Redis and then it would run a
container called Redis so we're gonna go
in and if you don't have the Redis image
locally installed it will then pull it
from the registry then the new docker
container radius will be then available
within your environment so you can
actually start using it so let's look at
why containers are so light lightweight
they're so lightweight because they
really have been able to get away from
some of the additional layers that you
have in virtualization within VMs and
the biggest one is the hypervisor and
the need to run on a host operating
system those are two big big elements so
you can get rid of those then you're
doing great so looking at some of the
more advanced concepts within the dock
environment and we're going to look at
two advanced components one is docker
compose and the second is docker
swamp so let's look at docker compose
docker compose is really designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
containing isolation but allow the
containers to interact with each other
as we stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environments
using yamo as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
Apache server with my single database
and you need to create additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write a set of files using docker
compose to be able to help balance out
that demand
so let's now looking at docker swarm so
docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
docker environments within a single
platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your docker
swamp as we're treating each No
as a docker daemon and we're actually
having an API that's interacting with
each of those nodes there are two types
of note that you can be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the manager node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to and receive updates from the
worker node so if anything happens
within this environment the maginot can
react and adjust the architecture of the
worker node so it's always in sync was
really great for as large scaled
environments so finally let's go through
what are some of the basic commands you
would use within Dhaka and once we've
gone through all these basic commands
well actually show you a demo of how you
get you use them as well so if we're
gonna go in probably the first one is to
install docker and so you have yum
installed you just do young installed
docker and you'll install docker on to
your computer to start the docker daemon
as you want to do systemctl start docker
the command to remove a card image as
docker RMI and then the image ID itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric ID number that you
want to grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're gonna be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your doctor
daemon and download the images from that
registry con like the command line to
run an images docker run and then the
image ID and then we have the if we
wanted to pull specifically from docker
hub then we would have docker pull and
then the image name and : its tag to
pull a build an image from a docker file
you do docker build - T and then the
image name and colon tag to shut down
the container you do docker stop
container ID the access for running
container is docket exec IT container ID
- so we've gone through all the
different commands but let's actually
see how they would actually look and
we're going to go ahead and do a demo so
welcome to this demo where we're going
to go ahead and put together all of the
different commands that we have outlined
in the presentation for docker first is
just to list all of the docket images
that we have so we do sudo docket images
and we enter in our password and this
will now list out the images that we've
created already and we have three images
there so let's go ahead and pull a
docket image so to do that we'll we'll
go ahead and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select poll and then the name
of the image that we want to pull which
is going to be my sequel and by default
this is actually going to go ahead and
use the latest my sequel command my
single image that we have so it's now go
ahead and pull this image it's going to
take a few minutes depending on your
internet connection speed it's kind of a
large file that has to be downloaded so
we'll just wait for that to download
you will see the others have completed
swing for this last file to download
almost there once that's done we're
gonna go ahead and do is will actually
run the doc and Katina and create a new
container using the image that we've
just downloaded but we have to wait for
this to download first
alright so the image has been pulled
from docker hub and let's go ahead and
create the new docker container so we're
going to do sudo docker run - D - P
0.0.0.0
[Music]
come on Eddie come on Eddie and then put
in my sequel go on latest so we have the
latest version and we have our new token
and that shows our new doctor Katrina
has been created now let's go ahead and
see if the container is running and
we'll do sudo docker
PS to list all running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so you can see whether
it's actually listed there so we'll do
PS - a and yes there we are we can see
that we do have our new container we
want to see called latest and it was
created 36 seconds ago but it's in the
exited mode so what we have to do is we
have to change that status so it's
actually running so let's change that to
running State
we do sudo daca run - IT - - name and we
can name it
I sell sequel my sequel slash bin slash
bash and that's now gonna be in the root
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now an active container
sudo docker start and then would start
the scene it and then and we should now
see it
diarrhea it's now in the running State
excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and go and clear
the screen okay now what we want to do
is remove the docker container so we do
is check list of images that we have and
so sudo docker images here are the
images that we have and we have my
sequel is listed and what we want to do
is delete my sequel and to do that we're
going to type in sudo docker RM - F
image my sequel
run that command and what we'll find is
the image there's no such image okay so
what we actually have to do is we have
to go and see that the image is now gone
it's being removed excellent
it's exactly what one wants to see and
we can also delete an image by its image
ID as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to kill that image first
so we'll go ahead and we're going to
select the image ID we'll copy that
and it's going to we paste that it won't
be able to achieve run correctly because
the image is active so what we have to
do now is stop the image and then we can
kill it
so it's in the running state so we have
to
so we do sudo daca kill and kill SL and
they will kill the container and now
we'll see that the container has gone
and now we can delete the image and
that's gonna be the image gone with
image ID the bone easy-peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is - so here we are we've
listed all of the containers in they're
all gone
so it's gone to the next exercise final
exercise which is to actually I create a
badge image and we do a batch HTTP image
so let's go ahead and write that out so
it's gonna be docker run
- did - - name white is that's gonna be
the name of this HTTP service - P
eighty caolan80 - v-a
and quotes
dollar sign PWD close quotes go on slash
USR slash slash apache2 /ht dogs slash
httpd semicolon 2.4 run that in our
password again
so what we see is the port has already
been used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what sports are
running so let's do sudo images and see
which ports are being used because say
that the the port or the name hasn't
been put in correctly so sudo docket
images
PS sudo docker PS - a and yep there's
port 80 there
so it clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name so I think we have the wrong
container name here so as to go and
change that and we'll paste that in and
voila
there we go now working and we'll just
double check and make sure everything's
working correctly so to do that we'll go
into our web browser and we'll type in
soon as Firefox opens up type in
localhost
colon 8080 which was the report that we
created and there we are it's a list of
all the files which shows that the
server is up and running thank you so
much for staying with us today and
learning about how to use docker in your
DevOps environment if you have any
questions please post them below if you
have any questions please post them
below and we will get back to you with
answers if you like this video hit the
subscribe button and then then the bell
to get notified of new videos we have
new videos on docker coming out all the
time when we have other videos on other
devops environments as well coming out
we would love to hear what other videos
you would like us to cover put those in
the comments below
this is Matthew from simply learn having
you have a great DevOps day hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos de nerd up
and get certified click here